¡Muy buenas tardes Better!
Acerca de esta actividad, por favor,
claro que sí.
¿Cómo estás David? Muchas gracias por la cobertura,
pues acá nosotros a 1 000 por hora,
no hay mucha afluencia de gente y estamos muy felices
por eso. ¿Hasta qué hora se van a quedar
para que la gente también venga?
Vamos a estar hasta las 4 de la tarde
tratando de registrar la mayor cantidad de personas
posible. Hay un montón de fila,
pero bueno,
estamos haciendo todo lo que está en nuestras manos.
Es recomendación de la población este
día tan especial para ustedes que
van a recolectar firmas,
claro que sí. Bueno, los invitamos a que se sumen,
vamos a estar todavía un poquito más
y si se sumen, por favor sean dueños responsables,
tráiganlos con correíta, con identificación,
no vaya a ser que se escapen, se pierdan, ¿eh?
Más bien queremos nosotros fomentar la responsabilidad,
así que bueno, esa sería la recomendación